يعود مجلس الامن الدولي الى التركيز مجددا
على الوضع في الضفه الغربيه بعدما ركز
اهتمامه منذ السابع من اكتوبر خطابيا
غالبا على الوضع في
غزه
مل الامم المتحده سجلت هذا العام اعلى
معدل للضحايا في صفوف المدنيين
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه منذ العام
2005 وذلك بسبب العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وعنف المستوطنين اضافه الى
طيف واسع من الانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
والقانون
الدولي خلال الاسابيع الماضيه راينا
العمليات الاسرائيليه الاكثر كثافه منذ
الانتفاضه الثانيه الكثير من الضحايا
الفلسطينيين سقطوا في مناطق الف بعضهم
خلال تبادل اطلاق نار ومنذ السابع من
اكتوبر قتل 34 فلسطينيين منهم 79 طفلا في
الضفه الغربيه في ذلك القدس
الشرقيه المطالبات تكررت من اغلب
المتحدثين في الجلسه لاسرائيل لكبح عنفها
ضد المدنيين الفلسطينيين وقف كافه
الانتهاكات اضافه الى وقف
الاستيطان الولايات المتحده ركزت اكثر على
عنف المستوطنين المتطرفين وطالبت
بمحاسبتهم وابدت قلقا من تنامي عداد
الضحايا المدنيين في الضفه وغزه لكنها في
هذا الشان كانت موضع انتقادات من
روسيا لسوء الحظ فان الجهود المتعدده مع
الدول الاعضاء لحمل مجلس الامن على تبني
قرار يطالب بوقف فوري شامل لاطلاق النار
حتى للاغراض الانسانيه تواجه معارضه شديده
من قبل الولايات المتحده سياسه واشنطن
تنبع من موقفها الاناني الاحادي الجانب
الذي يهدف الى اخراج عمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط عن مسارها والتغطيه على اي
تصرفات لحليفها الاقليميه
اسرائيل وقد كان لافتا ان يحذر الامين
العام للامم المتحده في بيان صدر خلال
انعقاد الجلسه من ان خطر اتساع رقعه
الصراع سيستمر طالما استمر امد الحرب في
غزه مشيرا في هذا السياق الى الهجمات من
لبنان وسوريا والعراق واليمن اضافه الى
تصاعد عنف المستمر في الضفه الغربيه بسبب
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وعنف
المستوطنين